First thing we gotta do
to get the bike parade
canceled is raise awareness.
Yeah, we're going to need
poster boards, markers,
and lots of glitter and glue.
I can't believe Kenny
bailed on us
just because he thinks Jeff
Bezos is a bad guy.
Yeah, how can somebody
who gives you
whatever you want be a bad guy?
It's locked.
They're closed.
We're all closed.
Our coffee shop, everything.
But we're outraged
about something.
We need glitter and glue.
Yeah, well, when the Amazon
fulfillment center opened,
everything else
went out of business.
I let it happen.
I thought the fulfillment center
would be nothing
but great for the town.
Instead it's buried us.
But it's Christmas.
It's Christmas and we've
no presents, no decorations.
There's no one
who can help us.
Look.
Ho, ho, ho ho.
It's Santa.
I heard some people here might
need a little Christmas magic.
We sure do Santa.
It's only a couple of weeks
until Christmas
and we don't have
any presents.
Well, that's no problem
for the hometown
of my favorite holiday poo.
Where is Mr. Hankey?
Where is that old bundle
of Christmas cheer?
We ... we had to get rid
of Mr. Hankey.
Got rid of him.
Mr. Hankey did something bad
and we were forced
to make him leave, forever.
Jesus, what did he do
[inaudible 00:01:42] a kid?
No, he ... he tweeted
some inappropriate things.
He tweeted some
inappropriate things.
Oh, you bunch of
[inaudible 00:01:59].
I'm getting back
in my sleigh now.
No, no, no. Wait, wait, wait.
Please.
Merry Christmas.
Have fun sucking Jeff
Bezos dick you bunch of cunts.
I'm going down to South Park
gonna have my self a time.
Friendly ...